why do you think microsoft bought github
and what do you think is the future
great point i thought it was a brilliant
move i think they did because microsoft
has always had a developer centric
culture
like they always have like one of things
microsoft's always done well is
understand that their power is
developers right it's been
balmer didn't necessarily make it make a
good meme about how we approach that but
they're broadening that i think that's
why because they recognize github is
where developers are at right and so but
do they have a vision like open teams
type of situation right so yeah
are they just basically throwing money
at developers to show their support i
think so without a topology like you put
it like a a way to leverage that like to
give developers actual money right i
don't i don't think so i think they're
still it's an enterprise software
company and they make a bunch of money
they make a bunch of games they have a
big they're a big company they sell
products i think part of it is they know
there's opportunity to make money from
github right there's definitely a
business there you know to sell to
developers or to sell to people using
development i think there's part of that
i think part of it is also there's they
had definitely wanted to recognize that
that that you need to value open source
to get great developers which is which
is an important concept that was
emerging over the past 10 years that you
know
pi data
we were able to convince jp morgan to
support pi data because of that fact
right that was where the money for them
putting a couple hundred thousand into
supporting pi data for uh several
conferences was they want developers and
they realize that developers want to
participate in open source so enterprise
software folks don't always understand
how their software gets used having
spent a lot of time on the floors at
jpmorgan at in shell at exxon mobil you
see oh these companies have large
development teams
and and then you're they're kind of
dealing with the what's being delivered
to them so i really feel kind of a
privilege that i had a chance to learn
some of these people and see what
they're doing
and even work alongside them uh you know
as a consultant uh
using my using open source and trying
how do we make this work inside of our
large organization some of it is
actually for a large organization some
of it is messaging to the world that you
care about developers and you're the
cool
yep you're you care like for example
like if ford because i talked to them
like car companies right they
they want to attract you know you want
to take on tesla and autopilot you want
to take that right and so
what do you do there you show that
you're cool like you sh you try to show
off that you care about developers and
they have a lot of trouble doing that
and like one way i i think like ford
should have bought github like just to
show off yeah like these old school
company and it's in a lot of good point
a lot of different industries there's
probably different ways it's probably an
article
that you care to developers and the
developers it's it's exactly what you
like
for example
just spitballing here but like ford or
somebody like that could give
a hundred million dollars to the
development of numpy and
uh like like literally look at like the
top most popular projects in python
and just say
we're just going to give money right
like that's going to immediately make
you cool
they could actually yeah and they set up
num focus to make it easy yeah but the
challenge was is also you have to have
some business development like it's a
bit of a it's a bit of a seating problem
right and you look at how i've talked to
the folks at linux foundation know how
they're doing it i know how
in starting num focus because
we had two babies in 2012 one was
anaconda one was none focused right and
they were both important efforts they
had distinct journeys and super grateful
that both existed and still grateful
both exist um
but there's different energies in
getting donations
as there is getting
um this is important to my business like
i'm selling you something that
this is not a it's assault i'm going to
make money this way if you can tie it if
you can tie the message to an roi for
the company it becomes more
representative it's much more effective
right so
and there are rational arguments to make
i've tried to have conversations with
mark especially marketing departments
like very early on it was clear to me
that oh
you could just take a fraction of your
marketing budget and just spend it on
open source development and you get
better results from your marketing
like because how do those can i sorry
i'm going to try not to go
here what have you learned from the
interaction with the marketing folks on
that kind of because
you gave a great example of something
that will obviously be much better
investment in terms of marketing is
supporting open source projects the
challenge is not dissimilar from the
challenge you have
in academia of the different colleges
right knowledge gets very specific and
very channeled right and so people get
they get a lot of learning in the thing
they know about and it's hard then to
bridge that and to get them to think
differently enough to
have a sense that you might have
something to offer because it's
different it's like well how do i
implement that how do i what do i do
with that like do i which budget do i
take from do i slow down my spend on
google ads or am i spend on facebook ads
or do i not hire a content creator and
say like like there's an operational
aspect to that that some that you have
to be the cmo right or the ceo you have
to get the right level so you have to
hire at a high
position level right because they care
about this and this right or they won't
know how right right and and because you
can also do it very clumsily yeah right
and i've seen it because you can you
absolutely have to honor and recognize
the
the the people you're going to and the
fact that if you just throw money at
them it could actually create more
problems
you